so it's very likely that you have
different financial goals over different
amounts of time for example you are
likely or maybe you should have
long-term financial goals long-term
financial goals are like I want to make
sure I have enough money for retirement
and to be able to retire at a certain
standard of living or I want to ensure
that my children or my future children
that I'm going to be able to pay for
their college or I want to save up
enough money for a house or eventually I
want to pay off that house those would
all be long-term goals we're talking
about many years probably over many
decades then you could have medium-term
goals you could say let's say over the
next year I'm hoping to save ten
thousand dollars maybe towards a down
payment on a house or maybe to help me
purchase a car or really just to have
some rainy day money in case I lose my
job or whatever else might be happening
and then you could go all the way down
to your short-term goals your short-term
goals are hey this month I want to save
10 of my after-tax money or might be I
want to save 500 or I want to spend 10
percent less on eating out than I have
the month before
now it's really important to have these
different lengths of goals or these
different times of your goals and the
way I think about it is your long-term
goals you shouldn't be changing them too
frequently and I think some of the ones
that I listed are good long-term goals
for most people that you want to be able
to retire reasonably well you want to
help with your children's education you
want to be able to have enough money for
children or you want to buy a house now
they might change If your circumstances
change dramatically if you're able to
get a dramatically better job or if
you're to lose your job or if you uh if
if you get married these all could
change your long-term goals pretty
dramatically but you're not going to be
changing your long-term goals on a
monthly basis
now on the Other Extreme your short-term
goals might change pretty frequently
although even there you should put some
thought into it this month it might be
hey I want to see if I can spend 10 less
on eating out and then the next month
you just want to maintain your new level
your more frugal level of spending but
maybe you have another uh short-term
goal maybe that month you want to figure
out
um you want to be able to invest your
money better as you say look I have
money sitting there in a savings account
it's getting you know not even a one
percent maybe I want to figure out if I
could get a higher interest rate I want
to figure that out by the end of the
month or maybe you have some other types
of saving goal or spending goal so it's
it's useful because if you just had a
long-term goal it's really hard to maybe
break that down about how that affects
you this month what I encourage you to
definitely have those long-term goals
but then break it down if you have say I
want to save money for a down payment
for a house let's say you want to save
fifty thousand dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars over the next let's say
10 years you can then break that down on
how much you need to save per year that
would be a medium term goal and then
based on that you have to think about
well what should your budget look like
on a monthly basis how much money you
need to bring in how much money can you
spend and based on that you could set
your short-term goals and see oh I'm
actually tracking towards that medium
and that long-term goal